today Miss Powell is the annalen
professor of practice of global leaders
public policy at Harvard John F Kennedy
School of Government her book a problem
from hell America in the age of genocide
explores why the US government is so
little to stop the major genocides of
the 20th century it won that 2003
Pulitzer Prize for general nonfiction
the 2003 National Book Critics Circle
Award for general nonfiction and the
Council on Foreign Relations Arthur Ross
prize for the best book in u.s. foreign
policy a New Yorker article on the
horrors of Darfur won the 2005 National
Magazine Award for best reporting miss
power recently spent several months
working in the office of Senator Barack
Obama as a foreign policy fellow and
currently she is writing a political
biography of Sergio Vieira de Mello the
UN High Commissioner for Human Rights
and Special Representative in Iraq who
was killed in the canal Hotel bombing in
Baghdad in August of 2003 the title
she's chosen for her lecture today is
Iraq's collateral damage I'm pleased to
present to you miss Samantha power
thank you it's a great great pleasure to
be here
I always find it a great idea in the
abstract whenever Yale asked me to to
come back because I went to college here
of course Davenport college but then
when when the day actually is upon me I
find it actually more daunting than than
delightful
I like the drinking at the end of the at
the end of the day and I'm very glad
that the talk precedes the meal but it's
just very very intimidating I feel like
sort of infantilized every time I come
on to this campus anyway what I'm going
to do is talk about Iraq's collateral
damage perhaps not in the way that is
readily apparent by the by the title of
the talk often well for the most part
when one hears the term collateral
damage one thinks about the military
calculation related to proportionality
is the collateral damage that hitting
this particular target causes is that
proportional to the good that
eliminating that target does for yurid
for the to the military advantage that
it that it serves I'm not going to talk
about that we can talk about in the
discussion period ER and the questions
laws in war and deviance from laws and
war compliance with laws in war with the
US military in Iraq what I'm going to
talk about is is the damage that Iraq
has done to America's other foreign
policy objectives and and try to think
with you about how some of that damage
can be undone in advance of the dawning
of the Obama administration in January
2009 anyway so the what I'll do is I'll
break the talk up into sort of three
phases the first is the pre Iraq world
and and where we were prior to to making
war and there I'm going to do two phases
pre 911 and post 9-11 pre iraq then the
collateral damage and actually
what I take to be the most harmful
collateral effects of this war and it's
been very little time talking about the
the damage that Iraq has done to Iraq so
again we can talk about that in
discussion and then thirdly what do we
do from here how can we undo some of
this harm so first in the pre Iraq phase
of the human condition here in the
United States and the pre 9/11 phase
it's it's very hard to remember now
perhaps but there was almost no appetite
from the early 1990s from around 1993
1994 you saw steady decline in interest
in foreign affairs in this country
manifested of course in the Republican
victory in November 1994 and the
takeover of the Congress manifested in
the closure of news bureaus abroad by
the New York Times by The Washington
Post by even the sort of stalwarts of
international reporting especially true
in television the phrase it's the
economy stupid of course was the mantra
of the 1992 elections and this
insufficient attention to events abroad
had very you know harmful consequences
in places that I have written about like
Rwanda and and elsewhere Africa was in
the wake of Somalia especially really
just the dark continent quite literally
in that it was a place that that had
very little light shed upon it but it
also affected the Clinton
administration's attention to Al Qaeda
and to 9/11 the Bush administration's
attention to real national security
threats despite the ever incremental
incremental II more devastating and more
tactically shrewd attacks by al Qaeda it
was it was a phenomenon and a threat
that was not given the attention in the
bureaucracy or the resources that it
warranted now again taking us back prior
to 9/11 there was something in the
United States and the young people here
haven't I don't think really had to live
it but it was called the Vietnam
syndrome and
it persisted especially in progressive
circles but but really throughout the
country and it was a constant sort of
when we describe it as a loss of faith
on the part of the military that they
would get the political support that
they needed if they went to battle on
the part of the public and especially
the progressive public a real skepticism
about the desirability of America
wielding its weight around the world and
some real insecurity about America's
competence also in the realm of military
intervention now when one looks back one
can almost say that the Gulf War
vanquished the Vietnam syndrome there
was a sense of possibility you could
mobilize international coalition's there
were new rules in the wake of the the
fall of the wall but then no sooner had
the Gulf War finished or had we departed
then Somalia occurred and the tragic
events there in October 1993 and so then
you had in the 1990s no longer the
Vietnam syndrome but what became known
as the Viet mallya syndrome and it took
quite a while to kick that syndrome as
well but there was a belated
intervention in Bosnia that made it seem
doable and at limited risk to actually
come to the rescue of people in need but
that intervention was motivated largely
because of the domestic political
pressure on President Clinton then of
course the war in Kosovo where the
United States bypassed the UN Security
Council and went to war in service of
the Albanian cause there a war that
people unfortunately very very quickly
forget was actually almost lost it was
going to always be very difficult for
Serbia to quote-unquote win but as is
true with the terrorist networks today
not losing is winning and if it weren't
for the Russian decision to bail the
Clinton stration out and put significant
pressure on Serbia that war would have
gone on much longer there was a true
panic in NATO headquarters but anyway
that was remembered as a victory the
British got involved in Sierra Leone and
came to the rescue of a struggle
UN peacekeeping force there and that
went relatively smoothly which which
nothing had really done in Sierra Leone
for some time and and so suddenly the
Somalia syndrome not not exactly
suddenly but incrementally in the late
1990s it began to become something of a
distant memory among Democrats
we heard the tentative introduction of
the Clinton doctrine which was a
doctrine that basically said if we have
the capacity to help large numbers of
people in need and we can do it at
reasonable risk we should do so the
United States had taken no casualties in
its intervention in Bosnia and it's
relatively lengthy occupation with NATO
of Bosnia and in Kosovo the only
casualties it took were those from from
an accident East Timor in September 1999
was not a very much unlike Kosovo was
was actually a consensual intervention
but it was Indonesian consent after
sustained diplomatic pressure urgent
diplomatic pressure and isolation by not
only Kofi Annan and and President
Clinton but also by the ASEAN countries
and even by China so again there was a
sense of WoW on these in these tiny
little places maybe it isn't so hard
after all
and again among Democrats at least in
the mainstream of the Democratic Party
there was an idea that can implies ought
that is if you can do it as Clinton said
at reasonable risk
maybe you should plow ahead and Tony
Blair was of course at the forefront of
that perspective as well in the
Republican Party there were some who
shared this belief but there was also of
course this is pre 9/11 a deep deep
skepticism about what was known as
social work condi rice rota rota an
article in foreign affairs just before
becoming national security advisor and
and none of you who know condi rice
today would recognize the author of that
work nor any of her prior work and and
so 9/11 again which I'll come to
constitute a major rupture for many
thinkers who were the provided the
underpinning of the rationale for what
has occurred both in Iraq and and
thereafter
if one had to sum up the kind of
ideology or the theory that drove pre
9/11 foreign policy I would describe it
as mercantilist realism realism of the
traditional sense in the sense that you
still saw partnerships based on the old
Cold War saws of the enemy of my enemy
is my friend or he may be a son of a
[ __ ] but he's our son of a [ __ ] but
but thrown in with that was a kind of
liberal democratic belief a free-market
proselytizing ethos that held in Tom
Friedman's memorable words that no two
countries with McDonald's in them had
ever made war with one another and so it
really was a belief that if you could
propagate the American system by example
but also by diplomatic and economic
incentives that the world would be a
much safer place and this of course
abetted the retreat from foreign
engagement because in the with if the
invisible hand is going to work anyway
then you can actually afford to hang
back and focus on your domestic troubles
if one looks again in the pre 9/11 world
at the relationship with international
institutions I think in the in the
Clinton administration despite lots of
misremembering on the part of Clinton
administration officials today about how
great they were on international
institutions in international law the
attitude was very much multilateral when
we can unilateral when we must the
Bush's took over and the order was
reversed unilateral one we can
multilateral only when we absolutely
positively must and of course this had
an effect on US legitimacy it even did
in in the Clinton years although the the
the legitimacy or the mounting a
legitimacy was was less evident when
with the end of the Cold War there
wasn't an overarching narrative that
forgave this kind of defection from from
international rules at least among our
allies so there was a brewing discontent
with US power and it's on its
unwillingness to be constrained by
things international
now I must say when one looks back
especially at the early the first year
first nine months of the Bush
administration and remembers the erosion
the very very precipitous erosion of
legitimacy that occurred because of the
Bush administration's frontal assault on
international treaties on Kyoto on the
International Criminal Court you know
the famous the memorable unsigned of the
Rome treaty the john bolton described as
the greatest day of his life when he
applied whiteout to president clinton
signature on the Rome treaty again a
treaty that Clinton signed but didn't
push at all and and said he had no
intention of pushing but when one looks
at that precipitous and how different it
was to sign and kind of wish the ICC
well versus actually threatening to to
kill the court and and using America's
economic and military leverage to try to
get others to pull away from the court
but even even when one looks at that and
sees the damage that it did I must say I
find myself these days very very
nostalgic for that form of illegitimate
see for the legitimacy of Kyoto and the
ICC I'd prefer that kind of illegitimate
e to the ax legitimacy of Guantanamo and
waterboarding but but perhaps it's just
me and I think it's important to
remember that that is what the United
States was being judged on that that
sense of us being above the rules or
only friendly to rules that we made
ourselves now in that pre 9/11 world I
say because I imagine there a fair
number of Darfur students related
students here this is just in the realm
of human rights and genocide prevention
one of the kind of interesting things
that was happening before 9/11 that I
think has gotten you know incredible
steam since then is the dawning of a
recognition among in certain quarters in
this country that you simply can't trust
States democracies to do genocide
prevention or to promote human rights on
their own they will forever be doing
cost-benefit analyses and you know in
democracies citizens tend to elect
leaders to advance their interests and
not the interests of imperiled people's
abroad and so in the pre 9/11 poster
wandah world you started to see the
stirrings of a movement with some very
interesting and strange bedfellows
partnering and attempting to again
mobilize what what now is is talked
about as a permanent anti-genocide
constituency and I'll talk again about
that in in the context of Iraq then 9/11
happens and in that context that I've
attempted to to establish here changes
of course overnight the context in which
American foreign policy makers make
their decisions first of all in the
immediate wake of 9/11 you know the the
world United around the United States
and its victimhood
a very novel feeling for us of course in
this country that sense of vulnerability
but very very novel for people outside
the United States to view the United
States in in that way with that kind of
sympathy people remember the headline of
course in the Mon we're all Americans
now and even Yasser Arafat giving blood
for the victims of 9/11 now I wouldn't
call this legitimacy exactly because it
was of course ephemeral and and perhaps
necessarily ephemeral but there was a
certain store of political capital that
the attacks of 9/11 gave the
administration a huge amount of course
at home but even internationally there
was a relative unity around the idea
that the United States would respond and
a recognition that that response would
in all likelihood be military at least
with regard to those who were
responsible for the attack so with 9/11
suddenly all those foreign news bureaus
that had shut down and the waning
foreign aid budgets the the foreign aid
budget I believe for the year following
9/11 for the next fiscal year was
doubled that from before when President
Bush had made pledges not only to not do
nation building but to cut back even
further on this social work the as I
said the news bureau is opening up all
over the place although very selectively
of course in countries that were deemed
relevant to the so-called war on terror
and very interestingly from a from a
human rights perspective these
old saws of the Cold War about the enemy
of my enemy and he may be a son of a
[ __ ] and so on came under scrutiny
because when one looked at the enemy of
my enemy idea one noted very quickly
that Saddam Hussein was backed in the
1980s because he was the enemy of Iran
so he was deemed the the kinder gentler
dictator in the native neighborhood
Saudi Arabia was an example of a country
that we partnered with on the grounds
that better to have you know a country
like that on our side given the oil
interest and so on but then once saw
opening up the country of Saudi Arabia
are looking prying beneath the statist
veneer and one sees that in backing
undemocratic regimes in a world of
asymmetric warfare in inevitably your
engendering resentments of those who
resent the jackboot in the human faces
Orwell used to say but also the sponsors
or the the benefactors or the backers
are the uncritical supporters of those
regimes and and so in policy circles
where one might not have expected it and
you saw this especially of course in
neocon circles who many of whom had been
arguing for you know attention to human
rights you know again quite narrowly
defined but nonetheless attention to
human welfare in foreign policy but you
saw the beginnings of that conversation
a real shift in the Republican Party as
a whole and certainly in the
administration that was governing our
country part of the new recognition also
was that failed States which had seemed
absolutely the worst places that any
country in its right mind would expend
resources or send troops we're suddenly
seen to be very very dangerous so nasty
repressive States and fail States
commanded new attention for
self-interested reasons on the
recognition as President Bush put it in
his second inaugural that security and
liberty are intertwined and that we will
be safer over time the freer countries
are now I know many of you are skeptical
about that rhetoric and we'll come to it
in Iraq but the one thing I will say is
that there the the these correlations
were
in fact noticed whether there was
rollout on policy or whether a
relationship with Pakistan or Saudi
Arabia changed sufficiently or should
have changed even if you're looking at
Saudi Arabia from a human rights
perspective it's very hard to know
exactly what the the particular conduct
of Washington should be but I but I do
think it's important to note that these
conversations were happening for the
first time for good or bad I mean we
will see how some of that language of
course was hijacked now also the other
thing that happened before Iraq but
after 9/11 was the victory in
Afghanistan I mentioned already the
relative ease with which the United
States and its allies had intervened in
in in belatedly in Bosnia and Kosovo and
Australia and Australian led coalition
in in East Timor and the British in
Sierra Leone and then suddenly the
hardest place on earth the place that
tied down a zillion Soviet divisions the
war in Afghanistan proved in the short
term in the eyes of oddly enough people
within the administration to be a
cakewalk and if if we had the the
Vietnam syndrome vanquished by the Gulf
War if we had the Somalia syndrome
rendered suspect by Rwanda but but let's
say vanquished at least temporarily by
Bosnia and the success in the Balkans of
the military approach the the Taliban
added a new dimension and and to this
sense of wow you know American power is
we're so technologically supreme that
even the the we can even succeed and in
the hardest terrain on the earth and
there was a true hubris a very very
dangerous hubris that pervaded when when
coupled with ideas about dictatorships
and failed States of course could lead
to an incredible proliferation of
military engagements if you believe that
the costs of not doing anything about
failed states exist if you suddenly
believe that they may come back to haunt
you and you believe that there's almost
no costs to getting involved militarily
or that every intervention is going to
be a cakewalk then you end up sadly
conducting a war much like the one that
was conducted in
RAK the other point and then I'd like to
get to the collateral damage of Iraq but
the other point that I think is really
important to remember and very hard to
remember right now this moment in
history but is that in the wake of
Afghanistan wasn't just us
planners neo-cons and others who thought
that the United States could have this
great success abroad expending few
resources and and that people would just
melt away in our pads and and maybe even
believe that they would adopt our way of
life but on the part of rogue actors
around the world there was a true terror
of this us hyper power now run amok and
and the best example I can give you of
that is the government in Sudan in fact
after the war in Afghanistan President
Bashir who we hear a lot from today in a
very with a very very different tone
threatening you know jihad than saying
that any UN force in Darfur will be
greeted much the way Hezbollah greeted
Israeli ground troops recently but that
kind of taunting would have been
literally inconceivable if you had
talked or heard from President Bashir in
the wake of the war in Afghanistan the
wake of 9/11 he was so sure that Sudan
was next on the hit list that after you
know 20 years of civil war and ten years
of an on-again-off-again very
unimpressive peace process he scurried
to the table and very quickly made peace
thanks in part to John Danforth the u.s.
mediator but today even somebody of John
Danforth stature and Darfur has nobody
of Danford stature in play but it would
take you know President Clinton or
somebody of that stature perhaps to make
the government in Sudan budge today so
immune does the government feel but I
but I'll get to that in a second Sudan
in those days was so terrified of the
stick that the carrots dangled in order
to shore up a piece and that piece of
course was between Khartoum and rebels
in in the South and southern Sudan that
they scurried to the peace table and
just before the war in Iraq signed a
peace deal that is holding
perfectly to this day but a very very
different moment that that sort of post
9/11 when we're engaged when we're
bandying the American stick with the
knowledge of what a hyper power actually
had at its disposal a very very
frightened group of rogue actors on the
earth okay now to Iraq and and the title
of the talk and and what I'm really here
to talk about which is the collateral
damage that Iraq has done and then how
to how to redress it if at all possible
first of all the war in Iraq has eroded
u.s. power in ways that are almost
impossible to put into words even by one
who considers herself a writer it is
just the the the I think this war will
go down in the history books at some
point as the greatest strategic blunder
in the history of American foreign
policy I'd be very curious what what mr.
Shapiro thinks about that but if one
thinks about power and in the 20th
century of course there's hard power was
the the the the very typical metric you
know what your military budget was what
your technological supremacy was
militarily what your GDP was whether you
were in in debt or whether you were in
surplus you know what what was your your
hard power what were those tangible
things that you could rely on as a
country in the 21st century that hard
power of course is still going to be
incredibly important and when one looks
at Iraq and the effect that Iraq has had
on those two variables it's hard to see
it as anything other than then
catastrophic the overstretch of the US
military the exposure of the weaknesses
whether in terms of the kind of armored
equipment are in and so on that we
supply our soldiers in terms of the
thinness in fact of the roster and and
people having to be summoned for third
and fourth do you know tours of duty
National Guard and reservists and the
and the erosion I mean that's not just
evident to families who have to live
with those consequences that thinness is
have
now to to people all over the world and
then just the mere fact of course of
fighting now to Wars and and having
active battlefronts and evermore active
battle fronts in Afghanistan and in Iraq
profound overstretch the fiscal deficit
of course has been run up that the Iraq
has been paid for on the backs of social
spending of course domestically but also
future programs and spending and so on
so just the hard power we have a hard
power problem in fact even though we are
still have a military budget greater
than that of the next 30 countries
combined and our GDP vastly exceeds that
of even China and India combined so on
the hard power front we're overstretched
but we remain of course atop the global
hierarchy but what I'd like to suggest
in this realm of power and and really
draw attention to in the context of Iraq
is that in the 21st century I think it's
essential that we in the United States
adjust our understanding of what power
is and and and power is hard power in
part but power is influence and is best
measured by influence and the components
of influence are our military and our
economic resources of course there's
they're always going to be predictive in
certain domains but but the there are
two other very very crucial ingredients
apart from hard power that I think
comprise influence and those are other
people's perception that we are using
our power properly namely legitimacy and
crucially and much less talked about
other people's perception that we use
our power competently and so if you take
hard power legitimacy and competence as
the variables that comprise influence
there is just again no question of the
damage that Iraq has done now on the
competence front which I'd like to just
spend a second on I think it's it's it's
also important to note that Iraq is not
all that is affecting our competence
meter or our standing on the competence
axis the twofer of Katrina and Iraq
in the same calendar year I just just
has true has really been been
devastating I mean to go from being the
country again whether people liked the
United States or not there was still an
impression that the United States was
the country that put the man on the moon
that rescued Europe from two world wars
that gave the world antiretrovirals
we're no longer the country that put the
man on the moon I do think increasingly
we are the country of Iraq and Katrina
and so even regardless of what our
detention policies become regardless of
the hearings regardless of how we get
out of Iraq when we get out of Iraq
actually the performance is going to be
a true measure of our ability to
actually recoup our standing
internationally and I mentioned our
standing in the context of our influence
our ability to get what we want
now just remaining with this for a
second
all one has to do is just look around
the globe today and look at the Bush
administration's attempt to pursue a
range of objectives to gauge that
influence I mean whether one what does
the bush ministration want in North
Korea
please don't test that nuclear weapon
whoops Iran please don't enrich whoops
Sudan please stop genocide whoops
un reform the United States actually
took I think the most enlightened
position believe it or not on a number
of the UN reform proposals but the
disdain for the United States is so
great within international institutions
that even European countries were
reluctant to sign on to the more
intrusive management reform proposals
and we can talk about that again in the
questions not to get into it but on and
then of course one mentions Iraq and and
our ability to get what we want so let's
move to looking at influence as power
and and think about it how it can be
restored second aspect of collateral
damage apart from power that I think
again is worth looking at is the effect
that the war had itself on America's
other strategic objectives I've
mentioned our lack of influence of
easily those objectives but let's just
think about what the Iraq war itself has
has produced or what has come into being
in its wake first of all of course
another battlefront and other training
ground
for terrorists who you know may have
been present in some numbers in northern
Iraq and al Qaeda cousin in in northern
Iraq of course had nothing to do with
with 9/11 but nonetheless would have
been a problem inside some kind of
problem had there been no war anyway but
that threat compared to the one that
exists now and the cheer proliferation
of al Qaeda copycat cousins and so on
and militias and others who are crossing
borders it will there's just no question
that Iraq itself has become a a
terrorist threat of a wholly different
magnitude as a result of this war second
of course the obvious point that
Democrats make all the time by you know
taking our eye off the ball in
Afghanistan we now do in order to fight
the war in Iraq the diversion of
resources military and financial the
diversion of legitimacy and credibility
and summoning power that goes with that
erosion of influence we now see the
Taliban completely resurgent in
Afghanistan and a very very dangerous
second front now that will be fought for
by generations of Americans and you're
not hearing again out of Afghanistan
movement just yet but it's going to be
interesting to see at what point that
starts as well as the costs of that war
are increasingly born-again by one
sector of our society
third strategic effect by removing
Saddam Hussein and the Taliban at least
temporarily we have removed Iran's two
great enemies thereby making life much
much easier for a government that was
part of the axis of evil fourth
strategic effect the you know if you
look at the lesson of the North Korean
experience vzb the Bush administration
if you look at the axis of evil and and
your Iran and you say okay so the
country that has a nuclear weapon
doesn't get attacked but the country
that doesn't actually have weapons of
mass destruction they get attacked
because one wants to prevent them from
acquiring them better get a nuclear
weapon in a hurry
that would be the takeaway I think for
many many countries and there's
absolute direct correlation between the
proliferation fears that are being
stirred by activities around the globe
now and that choice between Iraq and
North Korea and the lesson that that
sends and then finally in terms of the
strategic consequences rogue states like
Sudan committing genocide or defying
international will like Iran or North
Korea just really aren't afraid of the
United States in the way that they were
for the better part of the last century
and that you know may be something that
other countries could compensate for you
know if we had a true Coalition of the
Willing that was emergent on civilian
protection on proliferation on nuclear
deterrence you name it perhaps that
would be less harmful that the United
States actually is no longer feared as
the as the 911 is the rescuer partly
because it's too busy to answer the
9-1-1 but partly because it's our
weaknesses of course become evidence
it's often better to keep the the the
genie in the box not to expose the the
contours and the weaknesses of the genie
and military force has now exposed as
ill-suited to these asymmetric threats
is not nearly as threatening by I mean
it's very threatening to countries that
have return addresses but to terrorist
networks it does seem that the
technological supremacy the United
States has worked so hard to achieve is
very ill suited to the nature of the of
the threats that we are now invoking all
right so now that's on the strategic
side third aspect of collateral damage
is of course the huge concentration of
power and the executive branch in this
country that has been offset a little
bit in the in the last couple weeks this
matters in its own right and I'm sure
many of you have strong views as to how
it matters and why it matters but it
also matters because the Al Jazeera
instant news world that that exposes our
eavesdropping programs and our debate or
lack of a debate about black sites
and you know unaccountable detention
facilities and so on only underscores
the the hollowness of our rhetoric about
democratization and and and human
security forth and no need to say much
about this we're more isolated than ever
before I will just anecdotally tell you
I'm as was mentioned I'm writing just
finishing a book about Sergio Vieira de
Mello who was the best the UN ever
produced she's not saying huge amount I
have to think of a better way to
describe my my hero but a very
complicated incredibly charismatic cross
between Bobby Canon and Bobby Kennedy
and James Bond will be my my new way of
putting it perhaps but um but Sergio is
from Brazil and was the Human Rights
Commissioner and was sent to Iraq went
very very reluctantly to try to speed
the end of the occupation after the
United States had bypassed the UN
Security Council he was sent to he was a
decathlete of nation-building he'd been
working for the UN for 34 years had been
run he'd been the Bremer of Kosovo and
East Timor and had been in Afghanistan
all over the place um and he was and 23
others were the victims of the
first-ever suicide bomb in Iraq it's
very hard to remember now but he was
blown up on August 19 2003 and I just
you know I'd come to the part of the
talk on in talking about collateral
damage about our isolation or about the
suspiciousness about the United States
and it dawned on me that this would make
a a good anecdote but just when I when I
went to Brazil I did a lot of work I
spent about nine months just reporting
the last three and a half hours of
Sergio's life because he was under the
rubble for for three and a half hours
alive and like everything to do with
Iraq we bungled the rescue unfortunately
because we had actually just by
predicating the war on a link between
Saddam Hussein and terrorism we had no
preparation in our armed services for
actually responding to terrorist attacks
against civilian targets believe it or
not so when the first-ever suicide bomb
went off there wasn't it was pure chaos
and there was no command and control and
so on so it spent a lot of time looking
at that and then went to Brazil had been
to Brazil a half dozen times to get to
know his family and so on and amazingly
I have not met a single person either
related to sergio or in
inner distant circle or complete
strangers who I've met through doing
media and American foreign policy so on
I've not met a single Brazilian who
believes that anybody other than George
Bush killed Sergio and to me that was
the most stunning thing he did George
Bush did not kill Sergio is our cow he
killed Sergio and and 23 others but but
that is the extent and that's Brazil you
know that is not Pakistan the fifth
aspect of collateral damage I'm going to
pull us out of this vortex of despair
here in a minute but the the I think
perhaps not not that we don't think
enough about but the degree to which
having these wars and and these policies
how everyone wants to define them over
the last three years including Iraq but
also our policies on elections in
Palestine and and our reaction to
Lebanon and so on but but but crucially
with Iraq the degree to which the
association of democracy which we
promote and with regime change
undermines the ideals and the concepts
themselves and and you just see in all
kinds of moderate Islamic circles at
distancing by dissidents and independent
voices from the language of democracy
not from their own ideals of course but
a real reluctance to be associated with
anything that is itself associated with
the imposition of democracy by military
force which is seen of course as a
contradiction in terms and we can talk
about that again in the discussion but
but this taint of the ideals that
actually probably will be central to
containing terrorist threats is
something that somebody has to
recalibrate and reclaim the the the the
principles that will at some point
hopefully undergird a more stable world
sixth and then there's just one more
point of the collateral damage
sadly humanitarian intervention such as
it was it was not a long life that had
lived but it is dead the concept there
is all kinds of rhetoric around the
responsibility to protect as many of you
know
the Darfur advocates among you and that
you could say that that is a normative
placeholder and a very important
consensus and and benchmark to have to
have put down in the ground but the
reality is for all of the talk and even
the General Assembly consensus that
there is a responsibility to protect and
for those of you who don't know I the
young people are forever referring to
this r2p
responsibility to protect and a lot of
people were of a slightly older
generation think that that is a Star
Wars character but the responsibility to
protect is the idea that when a that a
state and a sovereign has the first and
foremost responsibility protected
citizens and if they abdicate that
responsibility it vests to the so-called
international community and it's a
wonderful concept it was it wasn't meant
to be an antidote to the fears and
suspicions in the South in the
developing world that people like me and
and other humanitarian Hawks were
talking about a right of intervention
and people in the South were obviously
not anxious to see Western countries you
know meddling and using the language of
humanitarianism as cover for other other
ends so Gareth Evans and Mahmoud Sununu
came up with this other concept which
which then was meant to soothe States
and to to console them that in fact they
had the first and foremost
responsibility and and in the UN General
Assembly last fall all the countries of
the General Assembly agreed that this
responsibility existed and that they
were on side now the problem with the
great concept but that there's not a
single country on the earth that
actually wants to exercise the
responsibility so lots want to talk
about it and you know clearly the United
States was not a country that that took
the lead in many cases on genocide
prevention as those of you who know
Rwanda well no but now taking note of
the USA's inability to actually gather
you know rally troops from other
countries and the total unwillingness
reflexive reluctance on the part of
middle powers like Canada Turkey Japan
any of the European powers to step into
the void that exists while the United
States is
Tainted internationally that that
reluctance to step into the void is at
this point anyway fatal to the concept
and so that is actually my seventh point
as well sort of even apart from
humanitarian intervention other
countries are using Iraq as an alibi
largely because they are making
judgments about whether or not to step
up on civilian protection or on other
issues on the basis of their own
cost-benefit analyses but Iraq has
provided them with a very convenient
stalking horse and again on in fairness
on the cost and benefits side the the
sort of very sloppy lesson learning from
Iraq namely if that's what happens when
you go and help people better stay home
which is the lesson that some are taking
has left us really bereft of a community
of individuals even within states at in
government's who are willing to stick
their neck out on on behalf of civilian
protection now again related to this the
country's defecting and not stepping up
to create a kind of global Posse or to
tend to the Commons it is just very very
important to note that in the 1990s if
you wanted to get a Chinese dissident if
you were a human rights advocate let's
say and you wanted you hope to see a
Chinese dissident freed or you hope to
see antiretroviral drug prices brought
down patents removed etc if you wanted
to see intervention in Bosnia to close
down concentration camps you you went to
Washington now it's unclear with the
exception of the patent issue where you
go in fact when you want to see
intervention Darfur that the students
here have done such an amazing job
pressuring the Bush administration which
would much prefer to be aligned with the
Sudanese government to be doing
counterterrorism work to be shoring up
the the peace deal with Christians in
the south to be extracting oil I mean
like most states this is a ours is one
that would prefer to have those kinds of
dealings at this time but because of the
domestic political movement President
Bush has really been forced to
darfur front and center its atop the
list of humanitarian causes and that
it's even made its way onto the list
with Iraq Iran North Korea Afghanistan
and the other truly profound security
challenges that exist is a testament to
the movement but the problem is Bush is
probably the the global leader who's
least capable of summoning support in
the developing world and summoning troop
contributions from other countries so
we've we've reached this wall in the
movement that I hope we can talk about
the questions okay
just before I just want to wrap up
quickly with an account of at least some
of the components I think that we would
have to integrate in a new sort of tough
smart and humane foreign policy and one
that would try to undo some of this
collateral damage even apart from what
we what we manage on Iraq the first
aspect of the kind of power doctrine you
might say is is a return to realism but
for human rights persons say that not of
the morgenthau a in kind or the
kissinger in kind realism true realism
empiricism results orientation and what
this with this amounts to these days is
some understanding as started to again
brew in the wake of 9/11 that the way a
regime treats its own people is a very
good predictor of the kind of long term
threat that regime constitutes but that
intervening and by intervening I don't
mean militarily but diplomatically
economically when your foreign policy is
so instrumental where your regard for
human life in other countries is just so
clearly about whether or not they become
terrorists and try to come and kill you
it doesn't actually tend to work and so
again an empiric empirical relationship
to scrutiny of internal practices you
know yields a range of different
policies than the kinds that we have
pursued for a very long time part of
this empiricism also means a new
relationship to international
institutions because if you're actually
grappling
with the threats that lie on the horizon
whether you know global warming or
contagious disease or you know
transnational terrorism or failed States
nation-building and the kinds of tasks
none of these threats are threats that
can be met by single countries and
they're certainly not threats that can
be met by military force alone and and
that's especially true on the
counterterrorism front just an
interesting anecdote there I recently
heard the head of mi6 just recently
stepped down head of mi6 talked about
recruiting intelligence operatives
basically spies and contrasting what it
was like in the Cold War apparently
served for decades
I guess they always do but but he said
that people in the Cold War behind the
Iron Curtain used to just fall over
themselves to be a part of the effort to
bring down communism and he said
recruiting spies now is just like
pulling teeth it's the hardest thing
because there's no sense of a cause on
the other side even if you're not a
radical Muslim there's no sense of
gratification being associated with what
lies on the other side of the legend or
whether that's true or not - no but
that's that's the mi6 person so that
just again when one thinks about
empiricism you know surely that would be
a metric of a result we don't want and
that's something that we would want to
try to be to have a more compelling
story to tell on the other side I
started to talk about international
institutions you know the UN is such a
tainted enterprise not only because of
the scandals that has beset that have
beset UN operations whether oil-for-food
or peacekeeping scandals and so on but
the UN largely of course is the some of
the states that comprise it and
especially the most powerful states on
the Security Council so there is has
been over the years a lot of you know
finger-pointing it's been far easier to
blame a Kofi Annan for Rwanda or to
blame the UN if you're the people who
killed Sergio there's Eric how he people
blamed believe it or not the UN for
failing to stop the United States for
from going to war I mean completely
exaggerating the power of a group of
bureaucrats in New York but
but unless these international
institutions the the rules are 1945
rules for the most part the effort to do
UN reform this year produced very little
of consequence especially on the
management side especially on rendering
the Secretariat more limber to do the
kind of work that you know having some
kind of independent voice out there to
do peacemaking and so on might be very
useful so a revisitation of these
international institutions of
modernization of these international
institutions is itself a form of realism
given the nature of the threats and yet
right now you know our tendency as a
country is to show up in those
institutions demand the reforms that we
want and not do any of the kinds of the
kind of diplomacy that we know is
necessary and that we do even this
administration does bring to bear when
something is a national security threat
or is seen to be immediate I mean we are
in multi-party talks you know for North
Korea for a reason and and but that kind
of sort of sacrifice or that kind of
willingness to do things differently we
reveal our disdain for the tool by our
inability or unwillingness to actually
make sacrifices or change the way we do
business and in order to fix the UN and
you have to actually want a stronger UN
and not a weaker UN and so far
throughout America's relationship to the
UN with the exception of a little
shining moment at the beginning with
with Truman we have largely wanted a
weaker set of international institutions
for fear that they would constrain our
power that would actually have to change
and we'd have to do the diplomacy to
make others actually want to play as
well second point accountability of
course the touch phrase President Bush
said after the 2004 elections you know
we have accountability in America it's
called elections lo and behold he's
right but we don't have another or
haven't had another kind of
accountability I did I work for Senator
Obama for a year and it was really
stunned he's a member of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and was
stunned by this is the civics lesson I
somehow missed at Yale but it turns out
if you're in the minority party in a
one-party state especially in wartime as
such as its construed it's actually you
know you are at the mercy of Richard
Lugar
who's the chair when it comes to holding
hearings on something that I think apart
from Iraq has done more damage to our
standing in the world to our influence
than anything else and that is our
detention policies whether that means
the creation of off-site black sites or
Guantanamo and so on or what goes on in
those sites and of course for a long
time the the the fact that our foreign
policy team responsible for if not the
greatest strategic blunder in the
history of American foreign policy as I
think it is at least the greatest
blunder since Vietnam were since Pearl
Harbor however you want to date it and
the fact that our foreign policy team
remained intact sent of course not the
right signal abroad but but now that we
have accountability and somebody else
has the gavel Joe Biden in the case of
Senate Foreign Relations we have a
chance to undo this record I mean it to
me it was it was stunning when I went
down there to know that despite the
damage our detention policies have have
done to our standing and despite the
fact that the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee is there to debate in American
foreign policy and and the costs and
benefits of a variety of policies now
the single hearing has ever been held at
the Foreign Relations Committee about
detentions not one so I was done by that
so now we have the chance but the signs
are not terribly good they're there does
seem to be a great skepticism on the
part of Democrats that torture is a
winning political issue for them that is
being against torture is sound politics
Hillary Clinton came out two weeks ago
and endorsed the president's position on
the military commissions distancing
herself from John McCain's position
which was more Geneva Conventions
friendly in doing that she invoked the
ticking bomb he often vocht never yet
seen ticking bomb and the need to be
able to use truly coercive interrogation
techniques in such a circumstance John
Kerry had Bob Shrum do or Bob Shrum had
john kerry do focus groups in the 2004
election in advance of the three
presidential debates around Abu Ghraib
as to whether would be in John Kerry's
advantage to bring up Abu Ghraib in the
debates and the answer was no and so Abu
Ghraib if you go back and check the
transcripts was never mentioned in any
one of the three presidential debate
despite the damage that America's
involvement in torture has done to
American foreign policy so this is a
very big worry but it's so
accountability I think we have to see it
in a for thicker form just three more
points and then over to you
third is very relevant to the Darfur
students among you you you can't do
morality a la carte it is actually turns
out impossible and I hate even the
language of morality now it's it's a
terrible and we can't do human rights a
la carte however you want to put it but
when when President Bush because of the
political pressure denounces genocide in
Darfur and then stands up with the
podium and endorses waterboarding or
Dick Cheney says waterboarding is a no
brainer it is move beyond the kind of
traditional selectivity might say or
hypocrisy or whatever of foreign
policymaking I mean consistency is
probably it's something one can aspire
to but not something one can achieve in
foreign policy but this degree of
disconnect simply to the naked ear
abroad yields people even I was just up
in Canada speaking to the foreign
ministry there and even in Canada I mean
you can't do better than Canada
presumably the Conservative government
etc but they literally want to know what
is what is really going on with Darfur
like what is Bush actually up to it has
to be about something else it can't
actually be about genocide and and
that's because of just the the the
canyon that separates our relationship
to principle in one area and and and
another I think you can see this also in
the detention policies in fact to a
large degree you know when John Bolton
says the ICC the International Criminal
Court is gonna be dead on arrival on
signing it is the greatest day of my
life etc that's like a day in the life
of John Bolton or you know a particular
love affair that he has with with the
International Criminal Court then you
have the team of lawyers in the Justice
Department and in the White House
describing the Geneva Conventions as
quaint and coming up with the rules of
interrogation and so on then you have of
course the existence of the facility at
Guantanamo Bay the black sites in
Afghanistan maybe in Eastern Europe etc
and then and then you have torture
now for us we can we can at least I can
conceive of a number of different
individuals some overlapping but making
judgments creating those facilities
creating the rules in those facilities
dealing the ICC there's sort of separate
they're related they're part of a
certain ideology for sure but to the
naked eye in fairness it just looks like
we don't want to be subjected to the
scrutiny of the International Criminal
Court we don't want the Geneva
Conventions to apply and we want to hold
prisoners far away from media or legal
scrutiny so that we can torture the the
a la carte ISM that might have worked in
a non global age when when not
everything was as transparent now is
definitely a thing of the past okay
fourth point for correction mid-course
correction is on in the realm of
democracy promotion I mentioned earlier
that democracy is associated with regime
change it's also associated with electic
recei there is a sense that the United
States is commitment to democracy begins
in the weeks before an election and and
ends just after the votes have been
counted that elections are finished
lines in most societies however in
developing societies especially
elections are more often than not
they're certainly expressive events but
they're also seen as enabling devices
ways of that we're throwing the bastards
out and the really tough work of course
begins in the wake of elections and here
you know I'm not even just talking about
Iraq or Palestine but whether it's Congo
or places that are very sensitive these
days
what what what it would seem to me that
that that if democracy is merely going
to be defined as electic recei as I
think we have done too often not just in
this administration but we've done often
in the past that it would be better to
actually condition our foreign aid and
our engagement in societies through
international institutions but around a
concept that is thicker than elections
and thicker thus than democracy because
I do think the term has lost a lot of
clout in the last few years and the
concept that I think a lot about but I
don't think it's the right term and so
if somebody could come up with a better
term I'd be very very grateful but he's
human security because ultimately the
instrumental relationship
that people have with elections is
geared toward actually being able to put
more food on the table to get rid of the
empty bellies in the in in in in the
home and to be physically secure to be
free of violence is basically freedom
from want and freedom from fear and
elections are the route for many are
seen to be the route why does Hamas win
okay you know maybe some number of
voters really want to obliterate I mean
certainly some number of Palestinian
voters do want to obliterate Israel but
how many of those voters actually voted
for Hamas for that reason and how many
of them voted because there was a sense
that Hamas would supply physical
security with its militia and with
others and crucially because Hamas had
supplied Social Services in the in the
run-up to the election fifth and final
point especially speaking at a campus I
was completely apolitical before I came
to Yale so in a campus that at least
used to be a place where people would
discover politics and and progressivism
we have to be very careful whether you
Democrat or an independent or
progressive however you define but about
throwing baby out with bathwater now in
reaction to George Bush and and I don't
mean we even the Democratic Party in the
Congress because on foreign policy other
than accountability and oversight and
appropriation the levers are quite
limited in terms of even what to do
about Iraq but a recent poll in the
United States as a whole not just among
progressives found that 42 percent of
Americans believe that the United States
should now just mind its own business
and so I remember at the beginning I
talked about the appetite for foreign
engagement you know having plummeted
after the Cold War and come home it's
the economy stupid there was actually
the stirring of a very similar set of
attitudes in this country just when you
thought isolationism had been vanquished
permanently by 9/11 there is a new
version of it that is ascendant and
among progressives or liberals I think
it's especially acute a recent poll I
think it was done about nine months ago
it's not that recent anymore but I would
imagine it remains true polled people
who self-identify as conservatives and
those who self-identify as liberals and
asked what their three top foreign
policy priorities were the conservative
priorities
capture Ben I'm sorry defeat al-qaida
was number one the idea that it could be
defeated and not merely contained but
defeat al-qaeda stopped the spread of
nuclear weapons was two and three was
captured bin Laden on the progressive
side the top three were get out of Iraq
second goal of foreign policy was work
with our allies and third was stop the
spread of AIDS yeah now I'm all for all
three but but we have some other work
that we have to do as well and and I
think one of the great the true
travesties among all the many that are
going on in Iraq for Americans and for
Iraqis of the Iraq war is that we have
not had an adult conversation in this
country about foreign policy I'm not
sure we've had one in ages frankly but
but certainly since 9/11 it has been
such a political device Iraq you know
fear has been stoked etc that there is a
temptation to say basically because
threats were hyped there are no threats
and that would of course be a terrible
mistake almost none of the threats that
the United States faces on the horizon
are threats that can be met without a
thick domestic base you can't become
energy independent if the American
people aren't brought on for the ride
you're not going to be able to make the
kind of investments in human security
that will bring about a stable world and
you're certainly not going to be able to
you know make concessions in the realm
of international institutions and
actually sacrifice sovereignty in the
short term for a more coherent you know
set of global mechanisms to tend to the
Commons in in the medium and long term
unless that adult conversation starts so
I think President Obama will do it in
January 2009 but but I think we could
start it in advance thank you
well thank you very much for starting
the conversation a little sooner than
2009 which is probably what we need to
do we do have some time for questions so
yes sir well yeah you hear a lot of that
I mean Mugabe threatened to send over
election observers for this for this
election and but yeah I mean I think
that that was part of it I it's there
haven't you know it's it's good to have
at least created the impression that
we've we've cleaned it up I mean it's
good that that you know George Allen
didn't you know start a sailing the
Virginia accounting process but cleaning
that up is just just a part of the
larger story of us not having our act
together
yeah yeah that was the gloss anyway I
don't want to over that's a
simplification but it that yeah
got my Darfur yep
it's a fair point right
okay
well okay
let me just repeat could people hear the
question or maybe everybody could okay
so there's a question about Darfur and
basically as tainted as we are couldn't
the Democrats have made as their first
initiative other than removing John
Bolton really putting on the map in
Washington the prospect of a unilateral
military intervention in Darfur as a way
of invoking my examples of Bosnia
kicking the Somalia syndrome and and the
Gulf War kicking the Vietnam syndrome
couldn't we kick the Iraq syndrome by
you know actually intervening and
helping people in Darfur well first of
all you know Somalia was was over we
were not in Mogadishu when we went to
war in Bosnia we were not in Vietnam
when we went to war in the Gulf War
every day that we are in Iraq we are
tainted by our association with Iraq I
mean I you know to to me honestly and
I'm green bracelet where Darfur advocate
I've done you know I'm a as they say
card-carrying member of the Darfur
revering nation but the idea that we
would invade another Islamic country
with an Arab government even for a cause
like this and indeed especially for
calls like this is very very it's
exactly the kind of ala carte ISM that I
think we have to be careful of not
because the people of Darfur wouldn't
benefit for several weeks let's say you
know as soon as we go in and I mean the
Jannetty we would go running we know
that but then what and and then what
questions of course not the question
that was asked by the planners in the
Pentagon on Iraq I have no doubt this
Eric how these people would come to
Darfur I have great fear that that as
bad as it is in Darfur and I mean it for
all we know these in these coming weeks
it really is the final solution that is
underway that the Sudanese government is
planning I mean is the most helpless I
think I've ever felt in my whole sort of
foreign policy watching life but but you
know as bad as it is I think one of the
lessons of Iraq
is is that it can always get worse and
if the jihadis were to flock there now
that doesn't mean that not I don't I'm
not prepared to then give up and I'm not
sure I agree fully with your assessment
of our allies I mean yes we rescued them
in two world wars you know but it was
the the British who went to Sierra Leone
was the British who actually prodded
Clinton into going to Kosovo the British
and French put peacekeepers on the
ground for three and a half years in
Bosnia before the intervention occurred
in September in 1995 as did the Swedes
the Dutch the Canadians the Canadians
are in Afghanistan as are the Dutch amid
great political controversy now trying
to stop the resurgence of the Taliban so
you know but having said all that you
know most of those interventions were
done for the same reason we have done
ours they thought it was in their
national interest and some and the
public's that are getting very skeptical
about participation Afghanistan are
those who are saying wait a minute what
exactly why do we want to associate why
do we want to become the enemy of the
Taliban to wouldn't we be better off
building walls around us and you see
this in the Dutch debate and in the
Canadian debate but you know ultimately
you're not going to get I I think a US
invasion first of all it's just
unthinkable in the Pentagon as you know
but that just because it's unthinkable
doesn't mean it shouldn't be thought and
debated if it were desirable I would be
pushing it strongly even who was
unthinkable and Don Quixote like but but
I actually think it would be a very bad
idea and and thus that brings us then to
this terrible half-assed kind of
compromise solution in between which is
this un protection force of 25,000 then
you ask yourself where those troops
going to come from
well it'll be hard enough even if Sudan
were to consent to the protection force
to get countries to contribute
peacekeepers to that force I mean the UN
now has for all the criticism what one
wants to make again of these other
countries as I made in my speech there
110,000 peacekeepers now being fielded
around the world
you know man by a tiny little pipsqueak
staff in New York finding another 20,000
for Darfur is really going to be a
challenge and it is going to be
impossible you
it is war that people are signing up for
that is you know so then what well then
what you got to do is you got to somehow
peel away Sudan's allies like China and
even like France certainly like Egypt
and other Arab League countries and the
United States can try to do that it
hasn't tried I don't think with any of
the gusto and that's what we should be
pushing for domestically and what the
Democrats should be pushing for but
peeling away the aisle allies in order
to get Bashir to walk back off the edge
of his branch to get that force in in
order to get those to get tho that
consent that we need in order to get the
25,000 troops to do the protection that
we want there's going to have to be a
political story told as well and a
reconstruction story and a development
story and so you know getting if it's
this administration of its Andrea not
cos that that's who were stuck with
finding you know some other Trojan horse
or set of allies I was meeting with
general Dallaire last week or two weeks
ago also in Canada about Canada being
one of these countries but Canada South
Africa Jordan Turkey perhaps some kind
of contact group of stakeholders that
have more legitimacy in the Islamic
world and whose support Sudan actually
still cares about you know certainly
China would be atop that list and and
but doing so where you're presenting
both the stick and sadly the carrot
I mean Iraq has killed the stick so
that's the irony as you end up in a
position where you have to conjure up a
story about how Sudan gets in effect
rewarded for genocide in order to get
them to stop and to save the people who
could still be saved but it's very
pragmatic and kind of my post Washington
kissing Geryon side but it just the
invasion of Sudan by us what would you
know what would follow it really scares
me
well I think that uh hearings hearings
are will be good for the country and and
and very good for people like us
you know academics and so on and and too
many of them very bad for the Democrats
I mean they will very much give off the
impression of crying over spilled milk
and so on
what hearings can achieve prospectively
I mentioned on detentions that there
have been none on things that are deeply
damaging I mean I would love to see
hearings on those issues and a real
debate about I mean a return to the
debate on the military commissions on
habeas corpus and all of these things I
am NOT optimistic that this is something
the Democrats are going to take on in
the first year anyway of their newfound
glory but what I started to say was on
Iraq I mean you know in this miserable
sort of imminent and and I mean in the
misery that that will ensue one way or
the other in Iraq either
if if there's some kind of if bush
insists on is that we're staying the
course or shrinking the presence but if
Americans continued to die and Iraq
continues to deteriorate at the pace it
is and not a single progress report in
Iraq quarterly progress report in the
last two years has done anything other
than gone down in terms of number of
civilian deaths you know unemployment I
mean again I mean the whole country is
just shutting down and I should add that
the violence also is genocide or
violence which is not spoken about very
often and I don't use the term lightly I
mean it is of course a civil war but but
the way you know when you get pulled
over at a checkpoint and simply being a
Sunni is enough to get a bullet in your
head or simply being a Shiite elsewhere
in in Baghdad is enough to get a you
know you know a hand drill you know
that's a genocidal mentality that is
just being judged for something nothing
you have done but simply because of who
you are and your religious identity but
but one of the things that the the
reason to have hearings is
I mean partly it's retributive partly
it's what David Brooks used to say about
you the or said at one point about
Rumsfeld in the foreign policy team is
is you know when you when you drive
drunk you get a DUI and you get your
license suspended you know if you are
responsible for a blunder of this scale
you should at least have your foreign
policy license suspended and you know
why you know when you get behind a wheel
why is the wheel of the entire American
military not worthy of suspending well
that has finally of course happened but
the other thing is is to scrutinize in a
less ideological way these these
assertions that are made on both sides I
mean the side no one's gonna like this
cuz I'm sure everybody has their view on
what to do about Iraq but the the the
assertion made on the side of staying
the course which has been you know the
assertions made by people who have been
making these same assertions from the
beginning and now have no credibility
whatsoever and have revealed a grotesque
lack of judgment at every turn and spend
and thus you know clearly more
interested in in in preserving their own
reputations than and actually having an
honest conversation about how hard it is
to think about getting out at any you
know point but but but that the those
claims of you know we're actually as bad
as it is we're staving off a larger harm
you know what you may many here probably
disagree with those claims again because
of the lack of credibility of those who
are making them and because of the
manifest harms of being there but with
Democrats you're actually gonna have the
chance to to really battle that out I
mean I mean when they would say that
with with lugar behind it you would be
like oh yeah you know thank you for that
perspective and your brave service for
the country and you know we're really
you know thank you for taking all this
time to come up to Capitol Hill and
consult with the American people I mean
it was I've never I it was just the
worst experience I you can imagine
having is what you know with our foreign
policy going into the tank seeing how
oversight and accountability was working
so when they make that claim about you
know in effect the waters rushing
through the dike there's sort of 25
holes in the dike we have you know
fingers in ten holes so you may you're
feeling the 15 holes in the dike and the
water coming through but when we remove
the 10th hole you know then
okay we'll really have a field day then
it'll really be genocide run amok I for
one despite having studied this for the
last couple years I don't know any idea
what American troops do in Iraq and I
don't think many Democrats do either and
and so at least you know that mean there
is that sort of more it's sort of an
empirical function for it for having and
then those who say you know we should
just leave I think we you know we really
do have to grapple with those arguments
but but our foreign policy architects
have to be made to bring their games up
a third and final issue besides
detention in Iraq is foreign aid
appropriation and you know you could see
perhaps in in the the realm of Darfur
and you know they are they you know the
the the appropriators do have their
finger on the Iraq spigot you know so
shrinking budgets for Iraq will have
dire consequences for the Pentagon for
the contractors and so on conceivably
money would be made available for you
know UN peacekeeping and Darfur and
things that we have been very
parsimonious about in the past but let's
be real the Democrats are going to get
blamed for the disaster one way or the
other it's a disaster in Iraq there's no
happy story if we get out of Iraq it's a
disaster it's gonna be a disaster
disaster for us a disaster for them
staying disaster for us - a disaster for
them it's a question of which disaster
and and that's where you know somehow
getting beyond rhetoric and actually
trying to grapple with what these
unknowables are but what's really sad
about about taking both houses is that I
don't think the American people fully
understand how powerless senators are in
general you know to affect the the the
conduct of foreign policy I I was with
West Clark over the weekend in Chicago
and I he had toured the country and
promoted 34 candidate campaign for 34
people and was you know flush with
victory and the first question I asked
him as I said you know is this the kind
of corollary to : Palace Pottery Barn
rule you know where okay you break it
you own it was his point to the Bush
administration about Iraq but now is it
it's broken you win you know you own it
like now you own the store you own the
Pottery Barn you know it's your you're
stuck with everything broken and
everything fixed and and
and without the the commensurate
authority to fix it and and I thought
was really interesting Clark said
undoubtedly the election last you this
was you know on Sunday I think I just
what do they say Tuesday two days ago he
said the election on Tuesday so there's
just no question it's great for the
country bad for the Democrats I'm
stunned and that's a guy who who made it
happen may be very bad for Democrats
well I appreciate you asking the
question I actually didn't even talk
really much about Iraqi deaths which is
you know I've tried to a little bit you
know kind of disclaim at the beginning
but you know I mean the British Lancet
came out with a study that I don't think
is accurate but was very influential
abroad and made the front page of all
the Arab newspapers but that six hundred
and fifty thousand Iraqis had died
believe it or not since the start of
conflict in in March of 2003 I mean that
seems like a very high number one of
course I mean you can look at collateral
damage in two ways I I'm using the term
metaphorically and not legally or
militarily or how everyone wants to look
at it as you are but if one is looking
at Araki casualties some number of
casualties are you know of course
inflicted by US soldiers at checkpoints
in searches this sort of trigger-happy
or trigger unhappy in fact but tendency
of soldiers in now seeing enemies
everywhere and and increasingly
accurately seeing enemies everywhere in
Iraq there were instances you know the
famous wedding party very early on was
hit you know by American planes I mean
they were bombing the the the checkpoint
incidents are the worst I mean I mean
just the number of cars that have just
in approaching not understanding the
sign language and of the signs or and
then just gotten blown away and then you
look inside the car and it was you know
a mother a pregnant mother and three
children or whatever and and so there's
that portion of whatever the figure is
which I don't I don't know what the
figure is and I haven't been overwhelmed
by any of the of the I mean are overly
impressed by by any of the calculus I
mean several hundred thousand one would
think me right now 120 Iraqis are dying
a day on average that's
is that you know 40,000 a year that that
numbers just going up all the time so
you'd imagine a couple hundred thousand
which would include this collateral
damage or this you know American
inflicted casualties but then includes
much more a much higher percentage of
the deaths in Iraq are those that you
could argue are collateral damage the
u.s. invasion because they ensued in the
wake of the invasion but they're not
actually inflicted by Americans they're
inflicted by al Qaeda or by Shia militia
or Sunni militia or you know as it were
agents of the Iraqi government of these
these police forces or these the
military that we have trained so I don't
have a great answer but I you know it's
probably important also to say that not
you know not every one of the hundred
and twenty deaths a day not even a large
percentage of them are inflicted by the
Americans but when around the world when
people see deaths out of Iraq they
immediately are tallied at the foot of
this country because of I mean largely
so anyway because of our role in
precipitating the war before drawing out
procedure proceedings today to a close
which unfortunately that the hour has
arrived where we must do that I would
like to invite everybody to join us
upstairs on the second floor and can
continue this conversation which
certainly will go into 2009 and beyond
it just remains for me now to thank
professor power for helping us begin